the Joe Rogan experience I don't want to
do that to people I don't want them to
feel they have to have this experience
you can learn a lot about the mind this
book is as much about the mind as it is
about psychedelics right this is a book
that uses psychedelics to explore this
really interesting mystery called
consciousness and it's also exploring
the nature of addiction the nature of
depression all that all the illnesses
that psychedelics turns out to be very
helpful in you know but I'm not holding
a brief that people should do this I'm
not an ADD I'm not an advocate for
psychedelics I'm an advocate for the
research at this point I don't know
enough to say yeah everybody should do
this this is what our culture needs you
know I know I'm not in that Timothy
Leary ahead you know I think I think we
have a powerful agent that that there's
good data now that this can help heal
people who are really suffering and the
other reason for the openness that's
going on right now that surprised me
because I expected to get a lot of
pushback from the psychiatric
establishment and I and I looked for it
I called around you know I want to hear
the critical voice on the Hopkins work
on the NYU work and when I kept hearing
blew my mind it was like I remember
calling the head of the National
Institute of Mental Health to get what I
thought would be a really negative quote
about psilocybin research and he was
like no we have to look at this this is
really interesting research hmmm former
heads of the American Psychiatric
Association and the reason they're so
open to it is that mental health
treatment in this country is just a mess
I mean we only reach half of the people
who are struggling with mental illness
at all have any exposure to the system
if you compare mental health treatment
to any other branch of medicine oncology
cardiology infectious disease is
accomplished very little it has in
prolonged lifespan it's not saving lives
and yet we have you know soaring rates
of depression depressions now the
leading cause of disability worldwide
there are 300 million people with major
depression or treatment resistant
depression in the world right now
and suicide rates are way up partly it's
the vets but
in general the taboo is coming off is
come off suicide and suicide is climbing
rapidly an addiction as we know is
rampant so they need some new tools
there hasn't really been innovation in
mental health treatment since the early
90s late 80s with the introduction of
the SSRI antidepressants drugs like you
know paxil and Prozac
they need some new tools and that's why
they're open to this and that's why I
think it will be embraced eventually by
by the medical world well isn't it on
the ballot in 2018 in California they
haven't quite gotten out they're doing
their petition drive right now and in
Oregon - and so I don't know that it'll
get through this time it's a weird item
to put on the ballot because actually a
small minority people know what
psilocybin is when I on this show you're
the first person who said the ingredient
and met you didn't say the ingredient in
magic mushrooms you have some confidence
that your audience knows what psilocybin
is but but it's a unfamiliar word to
most people so I don't know how people
vote on that